[Music]
hello uh in this video I'm going to be
talking about weball o2o uh and in
particular our packages for for web
assembly so uh web R supports loading uh
R packages uh they have to first be
available on the virtual file system uh
but once they're there U they they can
be
loaded so there's a few ways to ensure
that those packages are there uh they
can be manually copied to the uh the
virtual file system location user lib
our library um but there's also a helper
function provided by webar that will
that will install our packages to that
location for you um this this helper
function also is connected to a binary
repository uh that uh contains uh our
packages built for web assembly um so if
you if you ask for a package that exists
in that repository it'll go and download
it extract the files and put them on the
on the virtual file system for you
um there is uh issues when it comes to
uh converting our packages to run on my
assembly uh the biggest issue is
probably that our packages with compiled
code uh need to have that code
recompiled so that it can run uh under
web
assembly um and that includes not only
the code that that exists inside an our
package but also any system libraries
that that code depends on so if you have
some some C code in in an r package that
that uses uh lib XML 2 for example to to
to pass some XML files um that that
system liary that XML system liary will
also have to be converted into web
assembly uh and provided uh so that that
package can run under under
webar so we've done some work in webar
020 to uh increase the number of system
libraries um available for use with
webar um and the way we do this is that
we have certain recipes that uh exist in
in the The webar Source repository um
and if you ask for these packages to be
built there's a command you can run to
build them all um it will go away and
and build all these packages one by
one uh for web assembly um and and once
those packages are built for web
assembly um the our packages can be
linked to use them um to to um to
include that code in in those our
packages so there's a selection of new
libraries here there there's various
Graphics libraries that that are used in
in the previous videos when I when I
talked about um the the Cyro uh bitmap
Graphics there so
there uh text rendering and Graphics uh
libraries um there's some various
utility libraries there's SQ light 3 for
databases um and there's also some uh
geospatial and computational geometry
packages like gos gal and pro um and
they uh are used to enable some extra
geospatial packages in in the latest
version of
web by including these system libraries
we've been able to expand the number of
our packages packages that are supported
by webar um and there those our packages
are hosted on a binary repository at
that URL there and this is the
repository that's automatically used by
the web install command if you do ask
for an r package in web
R so in the previous release um by by
the end of that release cycle we had
about 219 packages available for use uh
now we have more we have
10,324 uh which is about 51% of crown um
that's how many packages are available
in that binary repo now um I should say
that we haven't tested all of these
packages U what what available here
means is that a package is able to be
compiled by the inscript and compiler
for web assembly uh so that our package
can be compiled um as well as all the
packages that it depends on so if if an
our package depends on some other r
package if it's available uh in webar it
means it means that all of that uh
dependency chain has has been resolved
and all of those packages have been
compiled for web
assembly so um because there are quite a
few packages available now uh you can
use a built-in R tools to to list those
packages I think I think the function is
available. packages to to to list all of
those
um but it might be a bit tricky to to
to run through all that data
particularly if you just want to know if
a single package works or not so one of
the things we've done is we've updated
the the
repository uh so that the the index page
that if you were to visit that
repository um in in a web browser the
index page that you see after a loading
period looks like this and and it tells
you how many packages are available and
and it gives you a list that you can
search through so for example if you
wanted to know if ggplots available you
could just type GG plot 2 in the box
there and you can see okay package GG g
ggplot 2 is available um and and all of
its dependencies are also available so I
can use that package in web so this is a
really nice uh useful little tool just
to just to see which packages are are
now available for use in
webar um some examples of packages that
are now available tidy verse and tidy
models are are both available so if I
run that code it will it will go and
download those packages
um there they are um not all of the uh
tidy verse packages are available I
should admit um there are some that
can't easily be used in web assembly
because they need to connect to the
network um and direct network access is
one of the things that's restricted in
the web assembly environment uh but the
core tidos packages are there and can be
attached and the same with tidy model
the the Tidy models packages are are
available and and they can all be
attached so you can you can run your
tidy models code in in web and you can
run your your core tidy verse code in in
webar uh geospatial packages are
available so in particular that includes
the SF package for for simple features
so if I run this piece of code again
it'll go and download those packages and
and then run uh this small piece of code
that's going to uh plot a map for us
projected onto onto a certain uh type of
map projection so this some there's some
uh computational geometry going on there
um and then all of those state lines are
plotted with GG plot here in this
example so there are uh various um
geospatial uh data packages available
now to use in
webar uh and there's also database
packages so here is an example of the
DBI package uh being used with the RSQ
light package um database uh systems on
on on another on a server somewhere
connect Ed over over over the network
won't work again because network
connections are one of the things in web
assembly that's restricted but in memory
databases like sqlite uh is available um
so here's an example that U take some
data and and put it into an SQ light
database and then we have some SQL code
here that we can we can use to to query
that data so if if you're a user who
prefers to use R um with DBI to run SQL
code uh you you can do that so you can
if I change that code yeah
well
uh maybe I
can there we go uh you can change the
code and and get immediate results in in
webar you can see I'm not a SQL
programmer as you can see by the the
previous example but it does work you're
able to to run your SQL code directly
there um again uh SQ light probably the
only uh database that is well supported
here just because many other databases
will require Network
connections uh and finally uh the last
thing I want to talk about with our
packages is shiny and um HTTP UV which
is one of the support packages that
shiny uses um so the HTTP UV package um
again is based on network connections
it's it's a server that can listen for
HTTP UV uh sorry HTTP and um and
websocket traffic and then respond to
those requests so a a package shim has
been created uh for web
R um which is available on the on the
rwm um organization if you want to read
the source code for that um and what
that is is it's a package that acts like
HTTP UV but is reimplemented to be used
with webar and in particular what it's
doing is taking advantage of a
JavaScript feature known as service
workers and and service workers are nice
because they can act as Network proxies
so um normally when that traffic that
HTTP V would handle over the network is
instead being handled entirely client
side inside inside a JavaScript service
worker instead and that service worker
acts as our as our network uh server
when really it's it's all running client
side uh with this shim uh shiny apps are
able to run under rear and in particular
they can run entirely client
side so the way this works is that the r
shiny server software uh thinks it's
talking to http UV through its normal r
package API uh and another the other
side we have the shiny web client that
the user is interacting with that thinks
it's talking uh over uh the network to
to um the shiny server but instead that
is being intercepted as I say by the
JavaScript service
worker and then that proxy in the middle
between the the the shiny server and the
shiny client um converts those uh
Network requests captures them converts
them and sends them to web R um and web
works with HTTP UV to handle uh those
those messages uh and the responses from
shiny again are sent back to the the the
client at the front end uh through that
that that Network proxy through that
service worker um so through this uh
package uh shimming process uh we we're
able to run um shiny apps entirely
within the browser with both the front
end and the back end server all all
running inside inside a JavaScript
worker um this is a similar scheme by
the way to how life for python Works um
it's not exactly the same but but it is
a similar scheme um and so we're hoping
that in the near future we'll be able to
integrate this kind of thing uh directly
into shiny life to to create a shiny
life for R um which will take the
complication of of deploying apps uh
like this uh away so that um the the
general user will be able to use shiny
live to deploy our shiny apps in this
way rather than having to learn the
inter icies of how to use a JavaScript
service worker or deploy their own
applications in this way um I do have an
example so this is a shiny app running
directly in the web browser um and you
can confirm for yourself that this
really is running um entirely client
side because that uh output at the
bottom of the screen is the output from
an our console uh running a shiny server
um so so that output is is directly um
from from the shiny server itself um and
I could disconnect the network I could
turn the internet off and this would
still
work the code for that uh demo is
available on GitHub um so if you are a
JavaScript developer and you you know
about web workers and and service
workers uh you can you can read a little
more about how this works um in a bit
more detail on that on that GitHub page
uh and it also talks about some of the
requirements for deployment particularly
when it comes to setting um special HTTP
headers for for cross origin isolation
these this is something that's required
to get web are to run um in in this
environment so that's everything I want
to talk about our packages so uh do
visit the uh reppel app at the URL at
the top of the screen there and and try
this out load some packages and see for
yourself which ones work and which ones
don't um and if you do want to create
your own web apps it's available on npm
or via CDN and the documentation is is
at that URL there which is which is well
worth looking through if you are wanting
to integrate webar into your own web
applications uh if you do uh do any
interesting projects with web or and and
want to share them please do feel free
to feel free to email me my email is
shown on the screen there and I'd love
to see what kind of project you uh you
create with web thank you very
much